And now it's the old scout master.
Three Cubmasters are talking at a round table and the first one says: I don't know about
you guys how you guys are doing with uniforms and everything like that.
Our Cubs all have scout shirts and scout pants, but they seem to wear the shirts out
in like within a year
They get torn and worn out. and the second Cubmaster pipes up and says: well, you
know, our guys seem to do okay with the shirts, but it seems like within six
months the handbooks are all worn out and torn to pieces.
It's amazing how quick they wear things out.
And the third Cubmaster pipes up and says: well, I got a topper for all of you,
because my Cub Scouts can wear out a den leader in about 20 minutes.
Hey, Adam Cox, the Google Plus.
Thank you very much for the joke.
All right,
This is podcast number one 16..
Hey, welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast.
This is Clark Greene.
Always good to hear from folks out there,
So let's look in the mailbag this week.
Oh, it's a little thin this week, but we did hear from David Maynard.
He said: I'm glad I found the site.
I love to read all things scouting.
We're glad you found us too, David, over at scoutmastercgcom.
That's the home of the podcast and the blog and the vast social media empire of Scoutmastercgcom.
So do come over and visit us and let us know what you're thinking.
And you know, when I have a thin week on responses and mailbag stuff, I always like to remind people
that that for a podcast to remain kind of a vital and interesting thing, we need to have
your opinions, your feedback, your ideas, your questions.
So get in touch at scoutmastercgcom at Verizonnet, scoutmastercgcom at Verizonnet.
Like I said, you can always go over and read the blog scoutmastercgcom.
You know our next podcast is the Scoutmaster panel discussion.
So if you have a question for the Scoutmaster panel, get in touch right away
And maybe you can get in on the recording session for the Scoutmaster panel discussion.
It's April and everybody's out camping.
That's what I hope.
I don't know about you, but around my area we're having what we are calling the March
Rollover Days.
It's been really cold.
We were out on an OA Weekend this past weekend and it was way down there in the 30s, which
is very unusual for our area.
But hey, it was good. sleep and weather,
Yeah, it was.
So would you indulge me for a little moment while I climb up on my soapbox.
Would you please
If you'd rather not fast forward a couple of minutes?
Here's an older boy myth in scouting,
And this is what the myth says:
You can't get older boys to stay in scouting unless you give them a bunch of older boy
stuff to do.
And that older boy stuff is: well, we're going to go whitewater rafting, go on ski trips,
We're going to have a ferris wheel at the meeting place,
We're going to have a half pipe out at summer camp and everything like that.
We have to distract them.
We have to entertain them so that they'll want to stay with us and do exciting and
cool things.
Now we age out- two or three boys out of a troop of 30 every year.
So the older boy program in scouting is not about distracting them and keeping them entertained
with these kind of wild things.
I'm all about high adventure.
I love it.
We go to Canada every year.
We've been to Switzerland. absolutely.
I think high adventure is a great thing.
But if you're trying to entertain your older boys and thus keep them involved, I think you're
barking up the wrong tree.
What's the older boy program in scouting?
Having the real responsibility to run their troop,
Having actual real leadership responsibility.
Without that, they do get bored and they do walk away.
And they might be placated for a time with these kind of big activities and things like
that,
But if they don't have real, actual responsibility to run their own troop- you know, past the
age of 14,, 15, they're going to get bored and walk away.
I'm sorry.
So I'm going to climb down off the soapbox now and we're going to continue with the
podcast,
This time on the Scoutmaster podcast. in Scoutmastership in seven minutes or less, we're
going to talk about fun.
Go ahead,
Ask your Scouts one of these days why they're in scouting and they'll say: well, it's fun.
Well, what in the world does that mean?
It's a good question.
And then we have an email answer about partial completion of Marripe Edges, and that's going
to do it for this podcast.
So let's get started.
Shall we Scoutmastership in seven minutes or less.
We did a recent survey that was trying to look into meeting and outing attendance for Scouts.
What encouraged them to come to meetings?
What kind of- you know- complimentary, conflicting things that they have that cause them not
to get to meetings or outings?
And one of the things that was mentioned as a real attractant for both meetings
and outings was fun,
Fun.
Well, everybody wants to have fun.
Cindy Lauper said best girls just want to have fun.
Why not boys?
You know what?
I think fun is something that we really need to have in Scouts.
I think that we also need to really understand what that means.
So fun means, in my experience, about three things.
You know this is just hey. we're just talking here.
This isn't science.
I'm just telling you from my experience. these three things are important for fun
And before we talk about them, I want you to start thinking like a 12 year old for just
a little while.
Go way back, do what you need to do, sit down in a quiet place,
Think about you know your time as a 12 year old and think about what motivated you and
what seemed to be fun to you.
So once I've got you in that frame of mind, this makes a little more sense.
So for our Scouts, friends are fun.
Scouts are really strongly motivated to hang out with their friends.
I mean, it's a primal instinct.
Do you remember this? as a kid,
I remember we would cut classes.
I'm not encouraging that activity,
But you know we would. we risked an awful lot to be able to hang out with our friends.
You know, if it came to cutting classes, going to class or being able to hang out
with your friends, oh, every once in a while we would cut a class.
If we had to spin a tail to tell our parents so that we could all go hang out
somewhere together, that's what we would do.
So it's a really powerful, instinctive thing. hanging out, just kind of being
around and doing things with your friends,
That's fun.
Even school can be fun if you get to sit next to your friends or even if you
just share a class with them.
I mean boys, we'll go to a lot of trouble and potentially make a lot of trouble
to be able to hang out with their friends.
So let's think of that as part of the equation of fun.
The other interesting thing is- and it didn't come to me like really fast-
It took a long time before I realized that challenge is fun, especially for Scouts.
I mean any kind of a physical challenge, from a 15-minute game to a five-day
backpacking trip, is fun,
And the more challenging the circumstances, the more fun everybody seems to have,
at least in retrospect.
So what are some fun things that we've done?
Well, how about being huddled under a tarp for hours at the end of a
portage trail up in Canada in this really intense, swirling electrical storm.
It wasn't like the most pleasant thing to do, but, man, it was fun.
How about slogging up five miles of switchbacks with aching feet and an aching
back and just swimming in sweat and having many more miles to go after?
when you got over the top of that mountain-
I mean, at the time everybody felt like they were going to die, but it was fun.
How about waking up one morning and finding a bear ate all your food?
Not fun,
No, very unpleasant at the time, but through the prism of memory and this kind
of magical thing that happens, these are incredibly great memories.
They are accomplishments and that was fun.
So friends are fun and challenges are fun, and even dismal, awful challenges
can be fun.
So really great challenges,
They are super fun.
Independence is an important aspect of fun.
I remember the intense sense of independence
We felt, you know, as a kid went on a Saturday morning. we'd get on our
bikes with three or four of our best buddies and we would head off for
the day.
That was just the best thing ever
At 12 or 13,. with a bike, we had the world at our feet and we just
had this whole kingdom that we could bike through.
Now no one knew exactly where we were or exactly what we were doing or
exactly when we'd be back.
We were on our own and it was magical.
We'd spend our money as we wanted, we would wear what we wanted to go,
we would say what we wanted to say and we would get back when we
wanted to get back, as long as it was somewhat close to the time that
the street lights went on, which was the universal signal for heading
for home.
Yeah, it's not that we did these marvelous, incredible things.
I mean, it was pretty humdrum, you know.
We'd ride around on the bikes, maybe go into McDonald's and maybe
be able to afford a thing of french fries or something like that
and, you know, go to places that we already knew about. so that in
itself wasn't the fun part.
The fun part was is we were on our own and we got to do it by
ourselves, and it was just a heady, incredible experience.
Do you remember that?
So scouts need to have some independence.
They need to be on their own to the greatest extent possible to
experience a sense of real independence.
That is tremendously fun.
Fun is not usually a carefully mapped out or managed experience.
It's usually a little chaotic and unpredictable.
So go back to being that 12-year-old self, and maybe a
few years younger than that, and remember birthday parties.
Now, maybe I'm all alone on this, but I remember birthday
parties as not being a whole heck of a lot of fun.
I mean, they could be really miserable.
So you go there, you have all your friends,
So that's one of the elements of fun.
You have cake
If you're the birthday boy or girl, you get presents,
But it was all kind of controlled and presented by adults
and I was supposed to react in predictable ways and my
friends were supposed to react in predictable ways
And somehow it could just be awful.
Not every birthday was awful, but some of them-
Oh, you're very,
I mean some of them- were not happy days.
I think every one of us can remember a similar experience,
All the elements of fun, but it was so highly engineered
It just didn't work out to be fun at all.
Fun is like one of these things that it seems like if you
make fun your goal, you say, well, this will be fun.
It has a really good chance of not being fun
If you make hanging out with your friends and being
challenged and having some independence- your goal.
you got a better and even chance of it being something
that is fun.
So we're talking about fun and scouting.
We aren't talking about matching tablecloths and napkins
and paper plates and a piñata and a cake with candles
and party favors.
We're talking about friends and challenges and
independence.
If those three things are in a walk around the block,
it will be fun.
If they're not, in a trip halfway around the world
to the great places, it won't be fun.
I hope that this helps.
I hope it motivates you to think about fun in the way
that a scout does and to make their experience all
that much better.
He's my favorite all-time boy scout.
You're my favorite all-time boy scout.
You were always on the beat boy, beat boy. yeah,
I'm hanging in the street boy, street boy. yeah,
We were dancing to the beat boy, beat boy. yeah,
You're my favorite all-time boy scout.
He's my favorite all-time boy scout.
Hi, this is Dr Paul Auerbach
And you are listening to Clark Green on the Scout Master
podcast.
Write me a letter, send it by name
Email. that is folks.
And here's an answer to one of your emails.
Pete Rivers sent me this email.
He says: great show Clark.
My question is about partial completions of merit badges.
We have several boys in our troop that have partial
completions on several merit badges.
Usually they are from summer camp.
Some of them are from several years ago
and the boys were not given blue cards
But a report was sent containing all the merit badge
information.
Do the scouts need to find another merit badge
counselor to complete the work?
We live in a fairly small rural town
and we do not have some of the merit badge counselors
that match up with what the boys are missing.
My advancement chair, a predecessor,
would sometimes check off the missing requirement
if it was something like you know:
show a finished project to your merit badge counselor.
Is that acceptable, or do all the requirements
for merit badges have to be checked off
by a merit badge counselor for that merit badge
to get credit?
I brought this up and my Wood Badge troop guide
said that I have hit upon a touchy subject.
Since advancement is part of my ticket,
I want to know the right thing for my scouts.
Any advice?
Well, first of all, Pete, thanks for listening
and thanks for getting in touch.
Short answer
Is an easy answer:
No,
It's not acceptable for anyone other than a counselor
registered for the merit badge in question
to certify its completion.
Now, that's not my opinion,
That's policy.
I don't know why anybody would have told you
that this is a touchy subject,
as if there were different ways to interpret it.
This is pretty much black and white policy.
I understand the spirit of maybe helping
a boy finish up a merit badge
by signing those last few requirements,
but if we do that,
we're really stepping off the reservation.
If you look at the new Guide to Advancement 2011
and you look at Section 7,
you will see a paragraph about partial completions.
Let me read that to you real quickly.
Scouts need not pass all requirements
so they can get a second counselor if they need to.
The application for the merit badge
has a place to record what has been finished,
a partial
So yeah, on the blue card
or the application for the merit badge,
there's a little grid on the back
and the counselor can fill out
what a scout finished
and then the scout can take that
to the next counselor
and use it to represent what was finished.
You're saying, Pete,
that you got some kind of a document
from the scout camp.
Well, basically it has the same effect.
A subsequent counselor may choose
not to accept partial work,
but this should be rare.
A scout, if he believes he has been treating unfairly,
may work with a scout master
to find another counselor.
An example for the use of a signed partial
would be to take it to camp
as a proof of prerequisites.
and partials have no expiration
except the 18th birthday. okay,
So there's nothing in that reading
that permits anyone
but a registered counselor
to certify completion of a merit badge.
You know, once again, it's not a touchy subject,
It's clear black and white policy.
The shortcut of someone
who is not a registered counselor
signing off the last few requirements
simply isn't acceptable.
It all stops and starts
with the guide to advancement.
if it's not in there,
It's not correct.
So listen, folks,
My experience is that you know
you've done some things one way in the past
and you go to something like the guide to advancement
and you look for supporting language to say,
oh well, yeah, of course this is the way that we do it.
But hey, sometimes people just get things upside down
or backwards or wrong,
Not because they're horrible, awful people,
It's just that they didn't know.
So when you ask and you know,
and you see that there's a change,
that's the change that needs to be made.
Now what I would recommend, Pete,
I wouldn't revisit any of the merit badges
where this has already happened.
That's water under the bridge.
Let's just not ever do this again in the future.
So you're in a small rural town.
You don't have all 130 merit badge counselors
or whatever it is now.
Well, you know that shouldn't be that big of a problem.
Your best way forward, in my opinion,
is you get the approved counselor list
from your council
And remember, folks, that councils have to approve
merit badge counselors.
You can't just approve them in a unit
or something like that.
If there's only one or two requirements
to clear up the badge
and they're kind of, you know, show me a report
or tell me what reply you received on a letter,
or show me a project, you know
the counselor may be happy to do this
via email or over the phone.
And if that happens again,
make sure we apply youth protection measures
that are in place, like copying third parties
on emails and things.
And if you're in a rural situation,
my guess is that counselors in your area
have kind of figured out how to make things work
for rural scouts without anybody having to be put out too much.
So, Pete, I hope that helps some of this kind of bad news.
The encouraging thing is you want to do things the right way.
That's always great,
And if you have a question for me,
if you have a question or a comment,
do get in touch and you're going to find out
how to do that in just a moment.
Well, thank you so much for listening
to this edition of the Scoutmaster podcast.
Here's how you can keep in touch.
First of all, go to scoutmastercgcom
and you'll find the Scoutmaster blog
and you can subscribe to receive updates by email.
You can subscribe to the Scoutmaster podcast on iTunes.
When you do, won't you please leave a comment
or review a rating?
You can also access the podcast on your mobile device
through Stitcher Smart Radio,
and you can get details about how to do that
at stitchercom.
You can call and leave a voicemail comment or question
at 484-734-0002,
and you can experience the wonders of Scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama of social media outlets.
That's right. follow us at Scoutmaster blog on Facebook,
Tweet Scoutmastercg on Twitter
and, for admittance to the exclusive Scoutmastercg circle.
Search for Scoutmastercg on Google Plus.
Please email me, Clark Green,
with your comments and questions and wild ideas
at scoutmastercgnet.
Remember, we're going to be recording
our next Scoutmaster panel discussion very soon,
So if you have a question that you would like to discuss
with the Scoutmaster panel,
hey, make sure to get in touch.
The Scoutmaster blog and the Scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America.
No, thankfully, our national organization
has a great deal more sense than to do something like that.
Nope, it's just me talking into a microphone
trying to lend a hand to scout leaders
and perhaps have a little bit of fun along the way.
Now, before we leave you,
let's hear from our founder, Sir Robert Baden-Palace.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and group camping
Why? thank you, sir,
Until next time.